des plages de sable blanc une ambiance
estivale et festive tout ça dans les
Yvelines c'est assez inhabituel et
pourtant Saint Germain en lait a bien
revêtu des airs de Rio de Janeiro le
temps de quelques jours au stade Georges
Lefèvre
du 16 au 18 juin Le Vésinet stade
Saint-Germain volley-ball organisé sa
première édition de la Semaine du
beach-volley c'est une première édition
c'est une édition que nous avons voulu
développer parce que nous voulons
vraiment faire la promotion du
beach-volley sur la sur la région
Île-de-France donc le club a développé
depuis deux ans une section beajolais et
dans le cadre de cette section nous
développons régulièrement tous les ans
des tournois et en France les tournois
de beach volley sont classés par niveau
et donc après deux ans et demi
maintenant nous arrivons au top des
tournois avec ce tournoi S5 qui est l'un
des tournois les plus faciles au tournoi
le plus dotés en France aujourd'hui les
20 meilleurs équipes masculines et
féminines se sont affrontés un spectacle
de haut niveau pour les beacher et pour
cause il s'agit du plus important
tournois national officiel de beach
volley de la saison organisée par la
ville c'est la quatrième étape du
championnat de France tous les deux
entre de mai à août on parcourt un peu
toute la France pour ces tournois donc
certes il y a pas le bord de mer mais il
y a l'ambiance il y a surtout les clubs
et tous les bénévoles qui sont très
investis pour organiser chaque tournoi
pas de bord de mer donc mais le niveau
est au rendez-vous c'est de soeurs qui
jouait sous les couleurs du Vésinet
Saint-Germain n'ont rien lâché une belle
bataille super bataille super
intéressante à jouer
très très fier de ce qu'elle a fait
Marion comme boulot elle a défendu elle
a tout réceptionné parce que du coup ils
savent sur elle et franchement elle a
bien tenu deuxième set elles sont devant
18,14 je crois si je me souviens bien et
on lâche pas et on revient et même que
dans le money time là quand c'est hyper
serré et ben
on a fait le taf
avec cet événement que le club souhaite
pérenniser dans le temps l'objectif est
également d'initier de nouveaux jeunes
qui représenteront les couleurs du club
en attendant Agathe Roland et Florine
Gosselin termine à la deuxième place
Marion et Lucie decaqueurs finissent 5e
du tournoi de Série 1